[MUSIC PLAYING]
We're in.
The show is about a family that's refusing to mourn.
They'll keep telling themselves stories.
They'll believe anything that they hear.
But the presence of Leanne in their lives
keeps them from having that conversation.
Congratulations.
We're officially in the carb delivery business.
Episode three was this very fun premise
that they're hunting Leanne.
Now what?
Nothing.
We wait.
I encouraged the writers and the directors to go to big places
and let me only see it through this box.
[DOORBELL]
The devices are the way you see the world.
I love that feeling of constriction.
Leanne?
You can finish the painting with your mind.
I use the house to talk about a larger tapestry,
and I think the basement and the hole in the basement
are the draw to the darker things, things
that bring us down.
There's a moment where Julian drops his wine bottle in there
and has to reach in and pull it out,
and it represents a lot of our vices, our darker instincts.
What's wrong?
What have you done?
Leanne.
Leanne!
What is really fun to play this season
is to what lengths will Dorothy go.
And I think she'll do anything.
I mean, she'll cross any line to get this child back.
This is what I want you to do--
pick her up off the floor, put her
in the backseat of your car, and drive her here.